Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie so new.
Rick and Morty is coming really soon because
a lot of you might not have ever seen it before
in the season three trailer is in black and
white.
I wanted to play the season two trailer just
to give you a better idea for the series then
I'll play the season three trailer right after
it.
So here we go Morty Kabbalist Michael Abbott
assassins I buy guns from your grandpa thing
Rick and Morty some things at 11:30 PM that
she to be a pretty good idea for the animation
the tone now here's the season three trailer.
It just that this one is in black and white.
So I'll explain everything after this is your
world not mine and I can go back to go back
to the one driven rent more literary yes yes
yes, come on, come on fresh fresh
some you are probably like what the hell just
happened.
So what this is is is Rick trying to escape
from intergalactic prison by gene splicing
himself with a hot dog when he turns himself
into a hot dog and starts grafting parts on
himself to make himself like the super being
so that he can get out at the end of season
two.
He was captured.
It was part of the big serialize storyline,
so I'll try to explain all that.
And especially if you've never watch the series
before looking like a quick recap of season
one season two like what the hell is going
on with the series is one of the most insane
animated series you've ever seen.
So if you're looking for like a game of thrones
level animated series, but this made as a
comedy then you have to start watching this
in all the episodes are on Hulu right now
so you can watch them for free, but it normally
airs episodes on adult swim.
So for those you wondering when the hell is
going to start airing season two aired at
the beginning of December last year they said
as of the end of September this year a couple
months ago all the episodes have been completed
and Dan Harmon the producers were hoping for
an end-of-the-year premier, so until you hear
otherwise it's gonna drop sometime in December.
Christmas comes early and I will be doing
videos for the episode, so be sure to subscribe
to get everything.
Make sure you turn alerts on so you don't
miss out is going to be awesome.
14 episodes know if you've never watched.
Rick and Morty before it's a series that's
loosely based on a back to the future riff
that Justin Royle and created then he Dan
Harmon, and Ryan really turned it into a bigger
series.
It had like a really short run for season
one.
They expanded that to 10 episodes per season
two there are now 14 episodes of season three
it's like a get like a little bit more popular
each year but the basic premise is that Rick
is kind of like this boozy dock brown character
but is more inspired by Dr. who and hitchhikers
guide to the galaxy.
So if you ever watched Doctor Who.
The rules are essentially Dr. who rules meaning
that they break the rules all the time but
it's a multi-verse show.
Rick has a portal gun that allows them to
travel between any universe that he wants
to go to, so they use that is the premise
for a lot of different episodes where they
wind up destroying their own universe, so
their backup plan is to just find another
universe that's almost like there's that was
really fun.
David Kronenberg fly episode.
A lot of them are themed after big sci-fi
movies and TV shows my favorite episodes are
all from season to Total Recall Luke whose
purging now in the wedding squanders which
are basic the last two episodes a season two
so one of the funny things about the series
is that they tried to mess with your head.
They include little Easter eggs separately
from the writers the background animators will
draw in things to the backgrounds to Easter
eggs that the writers don't know about so
sometimes when Dan Harmon in the other people
are doing commentaries will notice stuff that
they didn't know about when they were actually
making the episode like oh the animator added
that we didn't ask them to do that, but because
they surface a lot of stories from traveling
the multi-verse their house sustains a lot
of damages been through a lot of adventures,
so they just progressively make the house
look crappy and crappy are as it takes more
hits rather than make it look new again every
single episode like they would on family guy
or The Simpsons, so they have a really strong
sense of continuity, but most of the episodes
are stand-alone the loose running plot line
but all explained like a theory video is the
intergalactic Empire that's after Rick for
the first two seasons.
They eventually catch him at the end of the
second season and he has to escape the problem
with being one of the most smartest people
like Dr. who in the universe is that everybody's
after you and all Rick wants is to be left
alone, so is something of a rebel in the eyes
of a Galactic government the idea of there
being infinite numbers of everyone because
infinite universes is really important.
So, for each universe there is a.
Rick in a Morty it becomes a very big story
device in this ongoing Galactic Empire storyline
is a group of ricks that band together to
fight against the government.
But they have their own problems to they have
a secret base called the Citadel of ricks
we learned about that during season one.
So if you're watching the series for the first
time, I would recommend that you start with
season one, but I do think the season to up
the quality big-time me seeks and destroys.
Probably one of my favorite season one episodes
one of the things that makes it so much fun
to rewatch episodes is that Dan Harmon says
that they try to read it proof there episodes.
Just so that people who pick up the backgrounds
and look for little details clues will be
able to find thing, so it rewards multiple
intense viewings and they did say that there
is a secret storyline like a secret plot line
that they haven't revealed yet that goes beyond
the Galactic Empire.
So I'll probably do a video for that next,
but if you have any special.
Rick and Morty request videos just let me
know in the comments what you guys wait for
that to post you can click here for my Spider-Man
footage breakdown from Brazil, comic con and
you can click here for the guardians of the
Galaxy to trailer thank you so much watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight